A recent study revealed that about 2 million kids
are going to sleep each night without a bed of their own.
Well, after our next guest learned about this need
he decided to start building beds for kids in his community.
And six years later,
he has provided over 400 beds to families,
and his name is Robert Bosquez,
and he's an elementary school custodian,
and I am so honored that he is joining us today.
Robert.
(audience cheering)
Hi Drew, how are you?
Hi Robert.
We're so excited to have you and your community
spotlighted here on the show.
When we read that you said
there is an invisible need for this,
can you explain that?
How did you learn about this?
Tell us everything.
Sure, so six years ago
when we started this program,
we, myself included,
didn't know that there was this hidden need.
So we reached out to a local not-for-profit here in town,
they provide furniture for families here in town,
and we asked them, "What is your number one request?"
Right away they said beds.
So I was like, "Okay, well, you know what?
Let's do some fundraising.
We fundraise to build 40 beds."
And I said, "Let's put an application out
and let's see how many we get."
And we received over 100.
That told me right there that,
you know what, this need here in town
is a need that we need to fulfill.
And in 2015 you began building and donating beds
to those families and others.
Like, how does the program work?
So every fall we put an application out,
and once we receive 'em,
we always receive way more than we can provide.
And some of these stories that we hear,
you know, they're so heart touching.
It's difficult to tell a family,
"I'm sorry, but we can't provide you a bed."
But the rewarding part is when we invite these families.
So we invite these families that are chosen
to come and help build along.
And the excitement of the families receiving...
you know, some of these kids
are sleeping in a bed for the first time.
And when you make these beds
I understand that you take care
of every aspect of it, right?
So they're not just getting a mattress, right?
Correct, yeah.
So when we build we invite 'em to build.
We build the frame, they get a mattress,
they get the sheets, they get the pillow,
they get, that was a quilt.
Well, they get laundry detergent, books and a teddy bear.
So they get a whole package.
It's not just the bed.
Oh, (sighs) I love what you are doing
and thinking of every brilliant touch.
And what is it that you guys are often in need of most
in order to do this?
Well, as we all know
mattresses are the most expensive part of this.
And recently, you know, last couple of years,
we reached out to a local furniture store here in town,
and this year it's just gonna be hard.
It's gonna be tough because we all know with the pandemic
everybody has been hit so hard
that the ask this year is gonna be really tough
if we even ask.
I understand.
And our friends at Simmons actually reached out to us
and today they're gonna gift you
30 brand new twin mattresses worth over $7,000,
(audience cheering)
and more friends of ours, Tuft & Needle,
is going to provide 30 sheet sets that are brand new.
I'm so happy, and I thank Simmons and Tuft & Needle
for stepping up to the plate,
for wanting to be a part of this,
for enabling Robert to do what it is that you do.
And you really are a superhero
saving the world one bed, one family,
one whole setup at a time,
and we just thank you so much for that.
(audience cheering)
Thank you Drew for having us.
And I can't thank you enough,
our committee thanks you as well.
Do you ever get to do anything for yourself and your wife?
And I think you guys have an anniversary coming up,
any plans?
No, not yet.
Yeah, well, it's our 25th year anniversary.
My wife is a wonderful human being.
Of course, you know,
none of this is possible without her support.
So as of right now we don't have any plans,
but you know, we'll just sit back and relax
and enjoy our 25th year anniversary
and we'll see what happens next year.
Well, guess what Robert, you have some plans now
because the IHG Hotels & Resorts,
one of the largest hotel groups,
want to give you and your wife a luxurious vacation
to the InterContinental Presidente Cozumel Resort & Spa.
And it's located right on the coast of Mexico
amid one of the world's largest coral reef systems.
And it's all taken care of
during your six nights seven day trip,
and meals and flights all done,
all you have to do is snorkel and enjoy
and recharge the batteries
so that you can keep doing what you're doing.
(audience cheering)
Oh, (indistinct) thank you so much.
Oh, you're gonna make me cry,
I don't wanna cry.
(Drew laughing)
We're all so inspired by what you're doing here,
and you're so amazing.
Well, thank you Drew.
And again, every year what recharges my batteries,
if I can share this story,
we had a family come.
They rented a U-Haul because they wanted to make sure
that they had a transportation to take these beds home.
It was two young girls,
and the excitement of these girls
putting these beds together, you could just see it.
And once the bed was finished, we put the mattress on there
and we put all the sheeting and the pillows,
and she took that teddy bear,
she gave it a big bear hug and just fell back into the bed.
And that right there, from that moment on, told me,
"Guess what?
You're gonna be doing this every year."
(audience cheering)
Thank you Robert for being you.
It's the only thing I can think of.
And if there's any way that you can multiply yourself
or teach us all how to be more like you,
please do so
'cause you're amazing.
Well, go to our website to learn more
about Robert's Bed Blitz program
so that you can get involved.
We want to,
Simmons and Tuft & Needle are getting involved,
and it's it's game on
all in honor of Robert and his incredible work.
(lively music)